gary is with us in Mesa Arizona hi
Carrie how are you hey Dave good fit
real talky
you too sir what's up well my question
is uh is it a good idea to invest in
gold and silver like a Roth IRA uh and I
don't know if it's a good thing is it's
just tangible so that's my question it's
what it's it's solid piece because it is
good idea to invest in gold or silver no
um it there's a couple problems with
gold and silver one is anytime you're
analyzing an investment if you're buying
a piece of real estate or you're mining
a stock which I don't buy single stocks
but you could look at a single stock or
you're looking at a mutual fund or
whatever you any kind of investment
you're putting money into you can look
at and you should look at its track
record what it's done in the past to get
an idea of what it's worth today okay
and and and again idea what it's going
to do you know in the future and you
know if you look at gold prices I just
pulled them up they are all over the
place and up and down and up and down
and right now they're way down again
after a stock market out after an
all-time high and when you look at the
track record say over 50 years if you
put money in gold 50 years ago or you
put money in a growth stock mutual fund
50 years ago or you put bought a house
alright 50 years ago with the exact same
amount of money so we took a hundred
thousand dollars and we put it in there
and you visit 50 years later you know
you would find that gold has about a two
percent rate of return over that 50
years really yeah it's just a WoW it's
done horribly and so but but it's
pitched off of emotion where people say
oh you know if the economy crashes at
least I've got some gold right and the
problem with that is is that's also
mythology because when an economy
crashes no time has gold been used as a
medium of exchange on a crashed economy
since the Roman
Peyer uh you can't find it so because
what happens is your only going to give
you an example for instance during the
during the Civil War the south of course
tried to break away form their own money
and there were Confederate dollars
running around right right right yeah
and you know so when when that all
started falling apart and of course the
Union won the war you know what happened
it wasn't people start using gold it was
that they started using Union dollars
I've got I have Green Beret stop by here
the other day that was in in Iran when
Saddam fell and he brought me some money
some paper money with a picture of
Saddam on it okay and of course you and
I know what that money's worth yeah not
yeah right but guess what replaced it it
wasn't gold
it was another paper money another coin
with the new government and that's what
ends up happening people place their
trust in something and really when you
place your trust in that thing it's
because you think you can change it
exchange it with someone else you can
trade it but at no time have we had a
situation where you would take a bag of
gold down to the gas station and fill
your car up we've never had yeah and so
well you know it's like everybody fit as
well as the dollars worth nothing but
gold silver package so it is worth a lot
at the first birth yeah it's not it's no
longer based on the gold standard it's
only the only reason the dollars worth
something is because if I've got one and
you want to sell something you'll take
it that's the only reason it's worth
anything is it's a trust transaction in
other words and so so then it but that
makes gold being boiled down to anything
it becomes in the investment category
what we call it as a commodity at that
point and so like a bushel of wheat is a
commodity and you can buy futures on
commodities or you can buy actual barrel
of oil okay and what's you hear oils
down right now because you've seen gas
prices go down because all right oil
prices are down but that's a commodity
and oil goes up or down based on demand
and gold goes up and down based on
demand not based on it making money
because gold doesn't make money
only based on somebody if more people
are chasing gold the price goes up if
more people are running from gold the
price goes down that's the only thing
that drives the price same thing with
oil is a supply demand curve drives that
and so for that reason commodities in
general oil gold silver diamonds
anything that falls in that category the
only way it makes you like a rental
property makes money all right if you
buy stock in a company that company is
making money so that stock makes money
you might stock an apple they're selling
the crap out of phones right and our
billion billions of dollars and so by
owning a little piece of Apple when it
makes a profit you're there's money
going on there but gold is just sitting
there a barrel of oil is just sitting
there until somebody chases it and
that's what drives the price of it is
when people chase it so consequently
commodities are always more volatile
they always go up and down more up and
down more up and down more and that's
more than you ask for but a lot of
people are asking me this question so I
used your question as an excuse to go up
on a soapbox okay but bottom line is I
don't own any silver or gold except I've
got one really nice gold watch but I
don't know any as an investment at all
in any stretch because it's just it's
it's got a poor rate of return and
there's nothing that drives the price
except people's fear or greed which is
when they're running after they're
running away from it one of the two and
that's what drives the price on it so
hey man thanks for asking the question
appreciate you joining us hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you